[Music]
august saucina
lays out exactly what an entanglement is
in his eyes
on his new track featuring rick ross
which he dropped
saturday night on my shoulder got a
question in my willpower
beauty but a reputation real solid the
song titled
entanglements was inspired by jada
referring to her romance with the 27
year old r
b singer as an entanglement during her
recent sit down with husband will smith
at the red table you and i decided we
were going to
take our space and what happened yeah
and then i got into an entanglement with
august that's what i said an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship
absolutely rapper rick ross introduced
the song by noting
its significance
it was actually his idea for august to
put his own spin
on the term that has taken a life of its
own
get it up because that boy august got
real talent now
[Music]
to really sing now
up that album tomorrow
entanglement the album
although it wasn't an album the rapper's
idea
obviously sparked interest from august
who is now
capitalizing off of this moment
august first opened up about his past
relationship with jada
during an interview with radio
personality angela yee
where he claimed that at the time will
gave him his blessing
i actually sat down with
will and had a conversation due to the
transformation from their marriage to
life partnership that they've spoken on
several times
and it you know not involving
romanticism he gave me his blessing
and i i totally gave myself to
that relationship for years of my life
during jada's candid sit down with will
following august's comments she rejected
the idea
that will gave him permission noting
that only she could give herself
permission in this particular situation
i'm at the age now it's like this is me
it's my skin
it's my face this is my body love it or
leave it one thing that august and jada
can't agree on
is using the term entanglement to
describe their past together
in a recent interview with vulture
august opened up by saying
quote if you look up the definition of
entanglement
it's a complex and difficult
relationship it was exactly that
he goes on to say quote it was
definitely something complicated
a complicated dynamic if you marry me
know this
we're going to be together we're going
to be under the same roof
you might be on one end of that joker
with somebody else
always sitting down with somebody else
yeah
and i always said that's ridiculous but
we gonna be
yeah in this joker together in october
of 2018
jada opened up on red table talk about
her and will's transition
from defining themselves as a married
couple to having a life partnership
it's a life partnership in the sense
that we've created
a foundation together that we know
is for this lifetime to me it gives
us the freedom to create a different
context
first of all for ourselves and not have
to live up to the expectation of
what right people consider marriage to
right et later spoke with jada about the
candid episode
and she opened up about how her and
will's life partnership
resulted from her need for more freedom
i just felt like
i needed more freedom
and freedom in the sense of like
you know you can the public wants you to
be a certain way
your family needs you in a certain way
your partner needs you to be something
you know and for me that just was never
you know i'm really a free spirit at
heart i really am
and i always have been and um
i just felt like my life had got
constricted into this little box
and it was strangling me basically
people very rarely talk about the
courage it takes to be happy
how much bravery it takes to be happy
and really
that's what i needed to gain was the
courage and the bravery to do what jada
needed to do to be happy
you know and that was to dissolve
everything that was and create something
completely different you